So for you, for those of you
who weren't here yesterday,
I'll just say a couple words
or last class, first class.
I'll say a couple words about
what a happen basically forwards.
The course is really made up
of four different elements.
The first part is the standard financial
theory course that grew up in the last
10 years and a lot of major universities
pioneered by a bunch of guys who won
Nobel prizes in business schools.
And it's the method,
some of them quite clever and I
think fun methods for pricing,
financial assets and making
optimal financial decisions.
So you're going to learn
all these tricks and uh,
and how the financial system works and
you'll learn it both from a theoretical
point of view, the way they thought
of it in these finance schools. Uh,
and also from a practical point of view,
uh,
since many of these very same problems
come up all the time in the hedge fund,
I helped start, but then the, the, so
that'll be the main part of the course.
But there are three other things that I
want to concentrate on in the course. Uh,
so the second point is reexamining the
logic of laissez faire and regulation.
This is a dramatic moment in our history
now where there's tremendous pressure
on temporarily anyway,
on the government to establish
all sorts of new regulations.
There's also tremendous resistance to
establishing the new sorts of regulations.
So there's a debate going on
now in Congress and in the,
in the halls of academia about what kind
of regulations should we put in place,
what regulations would have,
would have prevented the crisis.
We've just lived through
the crisis by the way,
which I don't think we're done with yet.
So there's a very powerful
argument in economics.
The most famous argument
in economics, the, the,
the invisible hand argument that basically
says markets work best when they're
not encumbered by
government interventions.
So we're going to reexamine that argument
in the context of financial markets.
Then the third thing I'm going to discuss
in this course at some length is the
mortgage market and the
recent crisis after all,
my hedge fund is a mortgage hedge fund.
We founded it in 1994,
by the way,
which was,
uh,
the five years before that I was running
the fixed income research department at
kidder Peabody, which was the biggest
player in the mortgage market.
Then on the sell side that
hedge funds by mortgages,
investment banks create and
sell the mortgage securities.
So I was running the research
department at the firm that completely,
that did 20% of the market
and what's called Cmos. Um,
and then I changed to the buy side and
was at a hedge fund that bought those
kinds of cmos and bought subprime
mortgages, CDOs, everything. So,
uh, it seems, uh, you know,
I suffered greatly for the last two
years of the mortgage crisis and it,
it would just be foolish not to explain
what was going on and what it felt like
to be in a mortgage hedge fund while the
rest of the world was collapsing around
us. And it, it for quite awhile.
It's given me some great embarrassment
to have been part of it all.
On the other hand, now I feel like one
of those survivors that, uh, you know,
hundreds of,
of our counterparties and a much bigger
mortgage players went out of business
and we didn't. And uh, so I don't feel
quite as bad about it as I did before.
Uh, and I don't know every detail of what
went on in my hedge fund because after
all, I'm only part time
there. But I, you know,
there's a lot I do know about and so
I'll try and tell you some of that.
And then the fourth thing
is social security. Uh,
this is the biggest government
program and it's also a, so,
and it's a,
it's a financial problem,
what to do about retirement and social
security is the biggest government
program of all, the only thing
close is the military budget.
And so in terms of annual expenditures,
and so I'm going to explain how that
works and what the problem is and how it
arose and what I think the solution is.
So those are the four things, of course,
is going to concentrate on the
mechanics of the course. Again,
our homeworks every week there's going
to be a homework with little problems
illustrating what we're talking
about. I think that, uh,
so there's one already on the web.
Tuesday today,
every Tuesday there'll be one on the web.
It will be due the next Tuesday. The,
the PR, the sections we'll always
meet between Thursday and Monday.
So the problem settle,
come Tuesday,
you'll have two days of classes on the
material that the problem said will cover
and then you can talk to
the tas about stuff, uh,
between Thursday and Tuesday
when I presume you'll do
the problem set and that's
20% of the grade.
20% is the first midterm,
20% is the second midterm and
40% is the final. You know,
two midterms takes a lot of
class time on the other hand.
And it also takes a tremendous
amount of effort by the Tas.
And so I appreciate their
willingness to grade two midterms,
but I think you'll find it's helpful
to study the course and two pieces then
tried to do the whole thing or you know,
it's just,
it would be much better for you. I found
in the past they have two midterms. Um,
okay. So that's uh, uh, pretty
much oh and one warning.
The course doesn't require
difficult mathematics, but for me,
as I said in the first class,
it's very interesting that there's so
many subtle things that affect a financial
decision and you have to think about what
you know and all the different things.
You know,
you have to think about what the other
guy knows who's taking the other side of
the market. You have to think about
what he knows about what you know.
And you have to think about what he
knows about what you know about what he
knows. And all that thing in the end
boils down to one number, the price.
So it's, it's a, it's a philosophically
interesting problem. You know,
interactive epistemologies.
Some people have described economics
is interactive with epistemology.
It's more complicated than standard
epistemology and philosophy because there,
there were there, you know, they,
they go in circles thinking
about what one person knows,
whether you can know that, you know,
and stuff like that. In economics,
you have worry about what,
you know, what the other guy,
he knows what you know about what he knows
about what, you know, it's, it's, it's,
so it's a,
it's a more complex problem and yet at
the end there's just one number which can
be right or wrong. And so, uh,
when I was a freshman here at Yale,
my roommate who was a classics
major said that, you know,
his subject was much easier and much
harder than mine. That was math because,
you know, all I had to
do was be right. And, uh,
so I'm going to take advantage of that
simplicity and there's going to be,
every problem is going to have a
number that you're supposed to find.
And so it's not a complicated mathematics,
but it's involves lots of numbers.
And so if you hate numbers,
you shouldn't take this course.
And as I said before,
there's always been people who,
you know, you can be very smart,
you can also have a great future and
finance and not like numbers. So,
um, you know, you can make like
making deals and things like that.
Not Thinking in terms of numbers. So
just because you don't like numbers and,
and maybe shouldn't take this course
doesn't mean you should be discouraged
about finance.
It's just how I happen to teach the course
because that's what's comfortable for
me. So I'm just warning you about it. It
won't be hard, but there'll be relentless.
Okay. So, um,
I want to talk today about that second
problem about the logic of the free
market. And to do that, I'm going
to have to introduce a model.
So it raises the question of
what is a model in economics.
So many of you have taken economics
before you sort of know what this idea is,
but I think it's worth spending a
minute on it because it represented a
revolution in thought.
So for an economist,
a model means you distinguished exogenous
variables from endogenous variables,
the exogenous things
people can't control their,
just the weather and things like that.
Uh,
the endogenous variables are things
they can control and you're trying to
predict what the indulgence variables
are going to turn out to be like,
what are the prices be? What are the
consumption's B things like that.
How much income will people have?
Most of the indogenous variables.
So you have a theory,
which,
so the theory is it's couched
in terms of equilibrium.
There's a bunch of equations
which have to be satisfied.
F of Enx. So given the endogenous
variables and they exogenous variables,
exogenous and endogenous,
I wrote them in that order.
There's a set of simultaneous equations,
F that have to be satisfied.
And so you find Ecqua Librium when
given the exogenous variables,
e you find the endogenous variables,
x of t that solve that system
will simultaneous equations.
All our equilibrium models are
going to have that form. Um,
and one very important
thing they allow you to do,
which is the heart of economic analysis,
is comparative statics.
If you change the exogenous variable e
it will require in different x to change
to, to, to, to, uh, solve the
equations. So he has an effect, uh,
on x in order to restore equilibrium.
And so the prediction that had changed
and he has a certain effect on x is
called comparative statics.
Now,
how would a historian described
that a historian would say, well,
that's reasoning.
The environment is easy.
Why are you bothering to tell me about
what would happen if the environment
change from e to e prime? Well,
that's the heart of economic analysis.
So in history, you hardly
ever get much. You know,
people talk about it a little just
to raise the question, you know,
how would the Vietnam war have gone
if Kennedy hadn't been assassinated?
So they all bring that up, but then they'd
be, you know, you get two sentences,
all he was really gonna pull out, or
oh, he had been sending more advisors.
He was going to, you know, it would
have gone the same way. That's about it.
In economics,
the heart of the thing is to go off on
a tangent and figure out what would have
happened if the environment had
been different. So, you know,
why do a model well,
because many different such settings
can be described by the same model.
So it just saves time. It makes
things much simpler. Um, it, uh,
you know, from the, the counterfactual
reasoning, you're making predictions.
It helps your understanding.
And,
and then for the purposes
of the next few lectures,
the most important thing is you,
there are some properties of equilibrium,
like for example,
equilibrium is so good you wouldn't want
to interfere with echo Librium because
it makes everyone so well off and there'd
be a terrible thing to regulate. Uh,
so those properties of equilibrium rule,
we have to test the logic of,
so there's an obvious critique.
You can make them have a modeling.
The first person, uh, to make
a model was, was Ricardo,
who you I'm sure have heard of the
principle of comparative advantage.
And he wrote, he was the first guy who
didn't write verbally. He said, okay,
I'm talking about international trade
and why free trade is a good idea.
I could make a verbal argument
that's what everyone else has done,
but I'm not going to do it. I'm going
to say, suppose that England produced,
you know, with one hour of labor,
three bottles of wine and, and uh,
and so on. And he had a little, a
numerical example and he solved it.
And he showed that in that numerical
example, it's better to have free trade.
As paradoxical as it might have
sounded at the time, you know,
the Portuguese had such higher,
such lower labor costs. You know,
why shouldn't English workers be afraid
of being thrown out of their jobs when
trading with Portugal where the Labor
was so much less expensive? Well,
we explained why that turned out not to
be the case, but in terms of a model.
So malfa so you've also heard of a,
a contemporary of his and his rival,
but also his friend said,
you know,
this model stuff is ridiculous because
if you start making a model, you know,
the point of a model is to make
deductions from it and to analyze it,
analyze it deeper and deeper and deeper.
And of course the model to begin with,
it's going to be wrong.
And as you go deeper and deeper
in the analysis of the model,
the error that you made at the
beginning is going to get compounded.
Like he said, the Taylors
of Lacuna, you know,
who buy a slight mistake at the outset,
you know, doing their stitches. Uh,
you know, go wrong. The stitch
goes further and further wrong,
arrive at conclusions,
the most distant from the truth anyway,
that's what you might
think is wrong with models.
And the very first model was
critiqued by that reasoning,
but it's turned out historically that
modeling is the way to make progress in
economics. And everybody
does modeling. Now,
you'll find out as I talk more about
it, that the Coles Foundation, uh,
which has been at Yale since 1955 was
founded by a Kohl's undergraduate.
You'll hear the whole history of it.
I was the director of it for nine years.
That was the one most
important institution in the
world promoting the uses of
mathematics and economics. And it, it,
the revolution succeeded and now all
economists use models and mathematics.
Anyway, let's take an example
of the simplest model. You know,
there's so many different ways of
organizing price and trade. There's a,
you know, the, you had the supermarket,
the seller just sets the price.
You decide to buy it. If you go
to Jerusalem or something, you,
you in the Old City, you know that you're
haggling over everything. You know,
and every, you know, you offer
this and then the guy says no,
and you walk away and you come
back and it takes, you know,
half a day to argue the price. But
that's another way of arguing the price,
you know,
then there's the government could set
the price and the Paris bourse the way it
worked is, um, you know,
there, there would be a, uh,
a temporary price set and then supply
and demand people would announce how much
they wanted to buy and a supply didn't
equal demand. The price would get changed.
So it was tapped on woman's
groping and groping to the price.
There's the commodities futures,
just like the experiment we ran where
people yell at each other. There's a,
you know, computer bid, ask prices
where you do everything online.
There's the specialist
in the Stock Exchange,
there's one guy everybody has to come to.
And so he's responsible
for clearing the markets.
So I might affect, mentioned a little
bit of the history of the sort of thing.
Um, if I can hit escape, which
might be somewhat interesting.
Uh,
so the first people who had these well
developed markets and money where the
Lydians and the,
you know,
they invented money in six 40 BC and
they had gold coins and you know,
with all this money in trading,
they got very quickly to gambling and
prostitution for money. And, uh, you know,
Midas, the midas touch was a,
everything turned to gold was Lydian.
Um, uh, they've, they've discovered
all these, uh, mince in, uh,
in, you know, where their capital was a,
so they know that they were making all
this money and gold and stuff like that.
Uh, so they had open air markets, they
invented the retail markets. You know,
creases was one of the most famous, uh,
Lydian kings. And he's the guy, you know,
Richard's creases is a famous expression.
He's the one who went to
the Delphic oracle and asked
if he should fight the, uh,
great Persians, Cyrus the great,
and, uh, the Delphic oracle is usual,
mysteriously say at a great
kingdom will be destroyed.
And since it was Cyrus the great,
he figured it must be Cyrus's and it was
his kingdom that was destroyed. Um, okay.
So the Greeks copied a lot of that stuff.
They had their Agua raw,
which was the open market.
And um,
they had lots of trade and they
understood supply and demand. By the way,
this isn't a modern, uh, uh,
example in the, in the politics,
there's a story of failure.
These who predicts a bad harvest.
He's a great mathematician and he
predicts a bad harvest and he feel if he
figures, if he corners the wheat market,
he'll make a fortune when she does. Um,
Aristotle was famous for saying
money is a, just a convention.
It's not really worth anything.
People just agree it's worth something
even if it's just pieces of paper or
coins that's worth much more
than the coins. And how could
that be? And, um, anyway,
there's a long political
connection to that.
But the difference between
nature and convention to, anyhow,
he also said loaning it interest was,
was a unnatural and,
and terrible. But all the while
he was saying at the Delphic,
oracle was lending it. Interest
economics is a Greek word. You know,
household management. Xenophon wrote
a whole book about it. And one,
just one more little history, historical
thing. Hermes, the Messenger, God,
the God of information.
Um, so remember the,
the modern financial view of information
markets and information. Anyway,
he was the Greek God,
messenger,
God and God of information or commerce
comes from Hermes and the Romans who took
over the same uh,
God and called a Mercury's.
That's where we get the word
merchant from and market. Um,
anyway, uh, all right. I'm not
going to bother with all this,
but anyhow, so, all right, let's
do the history. I don't know,
I used to go on and on about this,
but anyway,
so the point is that in ancient times the
market was already established in this
idea of supply and demand
had already been created.
But there are many different
kinds of markets as we, uh,
as I've just said.
And they work in many different ways,
but we're going to describe
them in one, um, model.
So just to mention a couple
others, uh, the, the model that,
the experiment we ran in the class last
time, it's called the double auction.
And the experiment I told you about and
had you do was actually an experiment
that had, has been run before
and for the last 10 or 20 years,
many economists have run these
sorts of experiments, you know, for,
it's amazing that before that
was for 20 or 30 years ago,
no one thought to do that.
You know,
you didn't think that students with no
training and no experience could ever be
led to do something that was sensible.
But actually you did quite brilliantly.
And by the way, I've been told
that those of you who performed,
maybe you're still in the first two
rows, you have to sign a, you know,
even those of you who are left
at the end unable to trade,
you have to sign a release form so you
or disappointed you can't sue Gail for
you're disappointed faces appearing
on the Internet afterwards. So anyway,
the fact is we're going to see that
the people who were left at the end,
we're actually very rational.
In fact, nobody made a mistake.
I've done this experiment now 10 or 20
times and I would say that, you know,
half the time somebody buys something
for more than it's worth to them.
Nobody made a mistake and it almost
came out exactly as it should,
but we'll come to that in a second.
Anyway, that double auction, uh, is, uh,
the most complicated kind of auction.
But auctions have been
run for for a long time.
The first recorded auction you may
have heard about was Herat at us, uh,
describes the Babylonian
auction in 500 BC.
These are all going to be very
politically incorrect, but you know,
a lot of economics is politically
incorrect. Anyway, he just,
the first auction in 500 BC
was the Babylonians auction
off all the 18 year old
women as wives and they auction them
in order of most beautiful to lease
beautiful.
And so they got the very high price and
the price went down and down and down
until it hit zero. And then it started
going negative. But they use the revenue,
the first wives to subsidize the,
you know,
husbands who would accept the other
wives as it kept going down the, the, uh,
the next most awful auction was the Roman
Empire itself was auction to offset.
If you saw the movie gladiator, you may
remember, uh, that Marcus are really,
this is the great emperor and he dies and
then the evil communist takes over and
you know, he dies in the, you
know, he dies as a gladiator there.
And then there's the senator he sorta
hardly ever see, but you know, you know,
he's the good senator who somehow,
you know,
he appears a few times and you know that
he's a good guy and he's going to take
over. So his name is pertinent
acts and he does take over,
but he's a good guy and he gets killed
almost immediately by the Praetorian
guard and the Praetorian guard.
Then it doesn't know who to make emperor.
So they auction the whole empire off.
And so it's a bot by DDS Juliana's and
he doesn't last very long and he gets
killed. Two and the Roman legions come
back and kill him. So anyway, there was a,
I grew up in our band, Illinois and
he used to go to these livestock, uh,
auctions where they, you know,
they sell, they sell something,
they talk incredibly fascinating. I'm
picking, I'm going [inaudible] right.
Remember you don't talk like that and I
don't know how anybody could understand
them.
And then there's the famous slave auction,
so when they'd actually auctions
slaves, that would be, you know,
and you've seen it in the movies maybe.
And that's where the expression going
once, going twice, third last call going,
going, gone. That's what they used
to say at the slave auction. So the,
the double auction that we saw was kind
of what happened at the beginnings of
the New York Stock Exchange.
The first traded securities,
there are only five of them.
So how did they start?
There was the revolutionary war.
A lot of states had borrowed money and
issued their bonds and there are two
banks, Bank of New York and the National
Bank of the u s that issue bonds.
Those were the only tradable securities.
And so a bunch of states had issued
bonds. So what happened was, uh,
after the revolutionary
war, the, these nobody,
a lot of most people expected the
bonds wouldn't be paid back after all.
There was a huge expense fighting the
revolutionary war. These, you know,
the government didn't
have very much money. Um,
the price of the bonds had
already collapsed. And, uh,
Jefferson wanted the u s to just,
you know,
wanting to leave the states
and let them default.
And Hamilton said that that would
be terrible, that the, the, the,
the reputation of the country was going
to be made at what happened at the very
founding of the country. And it was
important that the u s never break debt.
So he persuaded Washington to have the
federal government by all the debt of the
states and basically pay it all off.
So none of the debts were broken.
Jefferson argued, that's crazy.
The people who originally
bought the bonds, who lent
the money to the government,
you know, the farmers who did it,
they didn't own the bonds anymore.
They probably all sold it for
$20. It was all these, you know,
despicable speculators who held the bonds.
You're only going to enrich them by paying
them off. So he just wouldn't budge.
And finally, Hamilton's supposedly, this
is a famous story, I assume it's true. Uh,
Hamilton went to Washington and said,
all right,
move the capital from
New York to Washington.
That'll make Jefferson happy cause
near as dear Virginia. And in exchange,
get him to concede that we
have to pay off the debt.
So Washington broker that deal and the
debt was paid and the u s since then has
never defaulted on its debt.
And you know,
that's virtually no other country
can say that. I mean, for example,
Russia has never paid a 30 year
debt. It always is defaulted. So, so,
so, and we'll come back to that a little
later when we talk about the crisis of,
of uh, uh, 97, 98. Anyway,
so these five securities,
three government bonds and these two from
the revolutionary war in two banks are
the only security sold. And they used to
be sold every day in a double auction,
exactly as the kind that we described,
where people would yell and scream at
each other and the whole thing would be
over in a few minutes and
that would be it for the day.
And then the next day they would do the
same thing over and over again. Well,
they had to stop that when,
uh,
Alexandra Dewar who is Hamilton's
assistant started, uh, you know,
using his insight information about
whether the government was or wasn't going
to make all its payments and whether
they're going to issue new bonds and stuff
like that. Uh, to try and
speculate on the market.
And he would do it all by borrowing.
He'd borrow a huge amount of money and
with the borrowed money, he buy bonds.
And if the price went against him, he'd
lose a lot more because he was leveraged.
And so it caused gigantic
gyrations in the market.
And the whole thing had to be, uh,
you know, changed and with, and uh,
it was no, it was made a much
smaller group of people and um,
you know, the, anyway, so, so
that was the beginnings of it.
And we're going to come back to that
because that view of the gyrations of the
market being caused by too much borrowing
and speculation is exactly the view
that I'm going to take and explaining
the most recent crisis. So how does,
so anyway, you remember what
we did in our experiment,
we had eight buyers whose
prices reservation prices
are those eight numbers up
there. That's what each person
thought it was worth to him.
Each person knew his own price,
but not any of the others.
I told you almost nothing about what
was going on. There was some context.
So they gave an example of a
person who thought it was worth 15.
So you had some idea probably from that
example that the numbers weren't 10,000
we plus you knew your own number.
But other than that you
knew absolutely nothing.
And each buyer knew her own number
and not any of the other numbers.
So here we have 16 different
pieces of information.
Everybody has an incentive to
keep her information secret.
Why should anybody admit
that she's willing to sell
at six that's only going to,
you know,
she'll get a worse price.
She's going to lie and say
the thing is much more.
She's going to make an argument that
says, well, these are football. Okay,
but to try the, the guy here,
the 44 guy, he's going to say,
this is a football ticket.
This is, you know, it, uh,
no, sorry, what am I going to,
let's say she's a, let's say she's a
44 she's going to say football tickets.
They're completely worthless to doing a
stereotype, either completely worthless.
Who would want to go to a football game?
I certainly don't want to go to a football
game. They can't be worth, you know,
any more than 12 or something.
So all the buyers,
the blue buyers are going to be making
arguments suggesting the price should be
low reasons why this stuff
really isn't worth very much.
All the sellers are going
to making arguments saying
this stuff is intrinsically
incredibly valuable.
Football tickets are incredibly important.
So that's the facts.
Now you need a model and a
theory that fits the facts.
And I'm belaboring the obvious, but the
obvious is always central to everything.
The obvious theory would go
something like, well, you know,
somehow these people are going to get
matched up and maybe 38 will sell to 44
and all eight things will be sold. And the
more transactions you have, the better.
And you know, what else might a theory say
a wrong theory? It might say, you know,
the more people in red are,
the more people making arguments
that the price should be higher,
the more compelling the argument will be.
You'll be overwhelmed by numbers and
you'll think that the price should be
higher because more people would be
arguing for a higher price. Okay.
But the theory, the economic theory,
the exact opposite of all that.
So the economic theory is,
uh, quite a shocking theory.
I think it starts with a situation where
people are arguing and talking about
the price.
They're not doing anything else,
but making arguments about the price
and making offers about the price.
They're haggling about the price.
The whole of the activity is about the
price and how to change it and what it
should be. The economic
theory, the first theory,
most important theory of economics,
supply and demand is that, um,
so that describes what happened is the
exact opposite. You can, the theory says,
let's suppose that a price
appeared out of thin air.
There was no arguing about the price.
Nobody even thinks they have any
chance of changing the price.
Somehow a price gets into everybody's
head the price of 25 and at that price of
25, everybody wants to buy,
buys as much as they want.
So Mr 44,
he thinks that the thing that ticket
is worth 44 he can buy it for 25.
He'll want to buy 40 he thinks it's worth
40 and the price is only 25. So again,
he's going to gain by buying,
he'll want to buy 12 things.
It's only worth 12 he's not going to pay
25 for it. And similarly the sellers,
seller number 10, she's going to
say, okay, I can get 25 for it.
I only think it's worth, it was worth
10 and it's a good deal for me to do.
So the theory says somehow miraculously
the price comes out of thin air.
It's given everybody taking that prices
given figuring they have no power to
change. It buys or sells all they
want, all they want at that price.
And so that's the theory.
So it's price taking out of thin air.
The price comes from somewhere.
Everybody Acts Nat by maximizing
doing the best for them, giving them,
given the price.
They all understand what the price is
and the price has miraculously been,
uh, imagined at exactly the level
that will clear all the markets.
So everyone wants to buy,
he's able to, and everyone
wants to sell. It was able to,
that's the theory.
The theory is completely the opposite
of what common sense suggests. Since,
as I said,
the whole thing was this grappling and
groping and pushing and shoving and
yelling and arguing about what the
price should be. And the theory says,
nobody says a word about the price,
they just take it as given
and then they act after that.
So this is the most basic economic
model is a paradox and good economics is
almost always a paradox. If you want
to make a convincing economic argument,
you almost always say it in a
paradoxical way. And so the,
going back to the very beginning
where we said what a model is,
the standard economic model is
you take the exogenous things,
which in this case or the reservation
prices of all the people you have to solve
equations which are here,
supply equals demand,
which determines the endogenous variables,
which are the price and
who buys and who sells.
And the reason that the theory is always
a often paradoxical is if you change
some exogenous variable, it looks like
it's going to move things in a, you know,
common sensical direction. But then when
people react to the change environment,
x is,
is a reaction to the change in e and
the change in x might be so big and so
important that a reverse is the apparent
change in eat. So you get these, uh,
surprising conclusions. If everybody
tries to save more. Cain said,
it may be that everyone will end up
saving less. Um, things like that.
Okay. So, so economics at its
best takes advantage of this,
of it's paradoxical nature at its heart
and uses that as a rhetorical device,
but it's a, so it's a non obvious theory.
Now why do we believe the theory? Well,
all those different examples I
gave you of markets, um, you know,
they all seem to fit where,
I forgot where they were the,
and we remember what they were. They were
the, I don't remember what they were,
but, um, you know, the seller, the,
the shopping center thing, the
haggling, the, the, the title mom,
Borst, the commodities,
futures, all that. You know,
if you look after the fact
that what people wanted to
do and what price emerged,
it seems to fit the theory.
So there's overwhelming evidence
that this theory seems to work.
And you saw that in our own example in
our experiment where you had no training
at all. Um, it came pretty
close. All those five, uh,
so all these five red sellers,
they all sold I think,
and the five buyers. The only difference
was that instead of 26 buying 20 baht,
okay. And the prices were all between
20 and 25. So they weren't exactly 25,
but they were very close to 25.
And the 10 people who were
supposed to impart and sold,
well nine out of 10
actually did buy and sell.
So it's pretty hard to match a theory
like that with so little, um, practice.
I mean it's, it's uh, you know, I've
always found it quite astonishing. Um,
okay, so any I, is this happening?
Okay. Does anyone wanna make a comment
or ask a question about this? Uh,
theory?
All right, well, what are the properties
of equilibrium you get out of this? Well,
everyone trades at one price, so this is
going to be very important for finance.
The idea that there's one price
for everything. Okay? Then
you can also define the,
um,
okay,
so you know what the theory is.
I already told you the exogenous
variables or the reservation prices,
the endogenous variables is the,
the reservation values.
The endogenous variable is the price
that emerges and who buys and who sells.
So why is this such a good outcome?
Okay, it seems like a terrible outcome.
There are those six people standing there
at the end unable to trade facing the
camera.
You know,
looking slightly embarrassed that all
their friends managed to buy and sell and
they couldn't do it. And what's the
matter with them? So they feel bad.
They feel discriminated against. It
doesn't look like it's such a great thing.
We know that there's another way of
making all eight buyers purchase from all
eight sellers just by, you know,
doing the corresponding one above.
What's so good about the market outcome?
It actually doesn't sound so great. Well,
the answer is it is great.
And what's great about it is that within
two minutes the market figured out
enough about what everybody valued the,
the football tickets at to
put the football tickets in
the 10 peoples' hands who
valued the most. Okay. So, uh, all right.
So in the end,
those five blue guys and those,
you know,
almost without that one exception
and these five a and the a one,
two, three read, uh, sellers, you know,
those three sellers and those five buyers,
the top eight people ended up with the
eight football tickets and the bottom
eight didn't end up with
any football tickets.
So the football tickets got put into the
hands of the people who value them the
most.
And so as I said,
if you just simply sat there and went
through 16 tickets and sorted them into
most and least, and then you don't try
to arrange all the football tickets,
it would have taken almost as long.
And that would have been with benefit
of knowing what all the numbers are here
in the market,
does it not knowing what the numbers are.
And the only access to information is
through people who don't want to reveal
their numbers and still the
market figured it out. All right.
So that's the message. That's
the, so the mod. So now,
okay, so, so we have a model which
is surprising, which seems to since,
which seems to, uh, uh,
describe the facts and which gives us a
surprising conclusion and an incredibly
important conclusion.
The market is an extremely
useful mechanism of eliciting
information and turning
the information into something
that allocates things
efficiently. And you know,
you couldn't do better than
that. You couldn't, no other,
no other arrangement would have, uh, uh,
put football tickets in the hands
of people who like them better. So,
uh, Hayak described the market as
a great calculating machine and,
um, well, uh, so it is,
now there are a couple of other things
that you can get out of this model.
Another lesson of this model is
that the equilibrium price is equal
not to the
average of the price of the buyers.
The average of the price of the sellers
are the average of all the prices or
something like that.
It's equal to what the marginal
buyer thinks it's worth.
So there's a critical marginal
buyer and marginal seller there.
They're almost indifferent to
buying or selling. You know,
they could go either way,
they're pretty close to buying or selling.
The price is going to turn out to be
very close to that valuation of the
marginal buyer.
Okay.
So somehow the margin is going to play
a bit. That's of the word marginal.
This is a invention in 1871 it's going
to play a big role in economic reasoning.
Okay. And then so, so it gives us a
completely different understanding.
You might think that the price of tickets
has something to do with their total
value or average value
or something like that.
It's got to do with the
value of a marginal person,
the person just on the edge.
So the comparative statics
are that the uh, as I said,
the surprising thing that if you change
a non marginal person, you take Mr 44,
the buyer at the top,
he changed them to 50 looks like the
buyers and now more desperate to buy won't
have any effect on the price.
You change that seller ms six,
you change her to two or to eight.
Again,
it'll have no effect on the
price because those two people,
the guy in 44 and the, and
the lady at six, they're, um,
they're not marginal. So they don't affect
the price. You add some more buyers,
you might think that they're arguing
for the price to be lower. As I said,
you're going to end up raising the
price or else having no effect on it if
they're not marginal. Okay. So, um,
now one more thing. One last thing,
one last message to this model.
If you didn't know we knew the reservation
prices ourselves because I set up the
experiment, but if you didn't know
it, you might want to infer something.
You could infer something from the price.
So part of finance is going in a
backwards direction. The theory says,
take the exogenous variables, predict
what the equilibrium is going to be.
Financial theory does that, but often
it goes in the reverse direction.
We can see what the prices,
that must tell
us something about the
exogenous valuations.
So a financial theory says, well, if the
price is such and such, it must mean that,
uh, the, at least the marginal
person valleys is at such and such.
And so that's why the price is that it's
the value of some, uh, special person.
So we'll come back to that
argument. Okay. So that, that's uh,
so that lesson of economics,
that's the first economic model,
the most important economic model we're
going to now have to generalize it and
in all kinds of ways, but it's always
going to come back to that same message.
And so Adam Smith, you know, he was the
one who first invented the invisible hand.
There was nothing
mathematical and what he said,
Ricardo was the first one to make a
model. Um, Mark said quite, you know,
I don't have time to talk about Marx,
but he had quite elaborate models
actually in his, in his, uh,
his verbal arguments conceal
a huge mathematical apparatus,
a on his death bed, by the way. He was
trying to learn calculus. Incidentally.
I'm so Jeavons mangere involve Ross 1871,
right after Mark's is famous,
you know,
capital came out in 1967.
They invented the idea of the margin and
things like that and the critique of uh,
therefore of Marx and Marx was trying to
figure out what they were all about. Um,
anyway, Marshall was a great economist,
Fisher, Samson, Hicks, Arrow, Debreu.
These are the people who most famous
people who extended this model and the
logic of laissez faire and regulation,
which we're going to uh, come to.
Now, what are the two ways we have
to generalize there three ways.
We have to generalize the model. We
have to think of many, uh, commodities,
not just one.
We have to think of people buying more
than one unit of a commodity. Okay?
That's called general equilibrium. And
then we have to put in financial things.
We have to put in stocks and
bonds and things like that.
It sounds like, you know,
things are going to get so complicated,
but in fact it turns out I'm going to
spend another class after this talking
about this. There's not that much
complication to get all those things in.
There'll be two more classes about this.
So I'm recapitulating all that you have
to know for the purposes of this class
about from introductory economics
and intermediate economics.
The only thing you have to know,
uh,
you'll hear now in these two classes
and some of you will find it's
incomprehensible.
And so that's why one good reason for
doing it now you find out right at the
beginning whether it's too complicated
to bother with. So anyway, I'm going to,
uh,
keep going now to extend the model.
So the biggest advance,
the next advance sort of,
which was related to
this is Adam Smith said,
how could it be that a water which is
so valuable has such a low price and
diamonds,
which are so useless basically to
everybody has such a high price. I mean,
there's not some marginal buyer who
thinks that diamonds are somehow more
important to him than water.
So how could it be that water's got
a much lower price than diamonds?
And everybody would say
that it's more valuable?
Well to answer that question,
what we have to do is we
have to imagine that there's,
that people are capable of consuming
more than one good. So for instance,
let's imagine that there's good acts here,
which is the football
tickets we had before.
And you remember that.
You remember our numbers? Let's just
go back to the numbers for a second.
I'll stay here for awhile. The first
buyer thought one ticket was worth 44.
A second ticket was useless to
that buyer. Well, suppose we right?
Oh,
suppose we write utility here.
Okay. Now this first buyer,
let's put this a 44 here.
This first buyer,
you might say got utility of
44 for holding one ticket.
If the old half a ticket, maybe as
utility would be 22. Now, in fact,
we know that half a ticket
doesn't get you into a game.
So as utility would really be zero.
But you know,
the the half when we're talking about
thousands of tickets to a football game,
a half or one, it's not so important.
Let's just say that his, his utility,
uh,
when up linearly with the,
with the quantity of tickets he
had to make a discrete variable,
a continuous variable is utility, goes
up linear at the rate of 44 per ticket.
Well, after 44, after one ticket,
he gets no extra utility out
of holding any more tickets.
So as utility might look
something like that. Okay.
But now let's imagine he wanted two
tickets and that the first ticket was
important to him. And the second ticket
he could take his girlfriend, let's say,
but she didn't, it doesn't want, you know,
he's not quite as worried
about her and some self.
So let's say that he,
uh,
for the second ticket gets
an extra 40 new tiles.
So after you get to ticket number two
is utility is going to be up to 84,
which is 44 and 40.
Now you notice that the rate of increase
of utility per unit of ticket is 44
here and then it switches to
40. Okay. Now why do I, um,
why do I, uh, okay. And you,
if he wanted one more ticket,
maybe you could go up.
Maybe you'd only get utility
one 20 for the last ticket.
Raizel for third ticket is utility
would say three it goes up like that.
Usually it would go up like this.
It's just a little flatter again.
Okay,
so here we have a utility function which
is increasing the number of tickets you
hold.
It's not restricted just having one,
but the rate of increase goes down as
you get more and more tickets from the
rate of increase of 44 to the rate of
increase of 40 until the rate of increase
of 36 now if you ask this person how
many tickets does he want to buy, well,
what's he going to say? How's he
going to figure out how much to buy?
Well suppose, okay, so this is utility,
but now I clean this person with buying
multiple tickets is going to behave
exactly like the top three people
up there would have behaved.
Okay,
so his utility at the top for three
tickets is one 20 for two is 84 for one is
44 those sound like important
numbers is totally utility,
but actually they're
not important numbers.
The important number is the margin
of utility. So the margin utility.
So if we go one,
two and three here,
the margin utility for
the first ticket was 44
the second ticket was 40
and the margin until it for the third
ticket was 36 so those are the important
numbers. The same numbers of that
are up there. Why is that? Well,
let's ask the guy. Okay, this person
who now likes three tickets after here,
let's say he's flat, so it goes
down to zero. Let's ask him,
how many tickets would he
buy at the price of 42 well,
from this utility function,
it's, you know, you have to
say, if I bought one ticket,
I have a utility of 44 minus,
let's say my utility function now is you
have x and money is this function of X.
I'll call this, you have X. I don't
want to write it out. This is,
you have x plus m for money.
So he says if I buy one ticket at
a price of 44 I lose 42 from here,
but I gained 44 from here so I'll
probably should buy one ticket.
If I buy a second ticket,
I go up,
this number goes up to 84 and now
this one goes down by 42 twice.
So maybe it's not such a great idea.
So what does he actually thinking?
All he's doing is he's looking at the
price and this access and comparing it to
is marginally utility. The extra
utility out of getting an extra ticket.
So if the price is 42 here,
he's going to say well at a price
of 42 the first one's worthwhile.
I'm getting more utility out of that.
After that,
it's stupid to buy another ticket cause
I'm getting extra utility of 40 compared
to a price of 42 so he's going to do
exactly the same thing as our single buyer
or a single ticket buyers did over there.
One guy whose utility goes from 44 to
84 to one 20 is going to behave exactly
provided he's got enough money to
afford to buy at these going prices.
He's going to be,
his behavior will be exactly the same
as the three separate individuals over
there. So in fact, the
marginal revolution,
so Jeavons,
mangere
and Vol Ross in 1871 all came up with the
idea at the same time with diminishing
marginal utility.
Hey Man,
he said if you have people who
consume multiple amounts of very uh,
commodity,
but they have diminishing margin utility,
there are going to behave very much
the same way as this little example.
So this little example, in fact, it's
going to be extremely, uh, instructive.
In fact,
it contains all the kernels of truth.
I'm a more general model where people
consume huge amounts of every god. Okay?
Just that they have
diminishing margin utility.
So I'm going to now describe
a slightly more complicated,
so I'm going to describe
this more complicated model.
So what's the,
what's the way of building a much more
general but hopefully still very simple
abstract model?
All of general equilibrium that will
capture and generalize the example we
already had.
Well,
the idea is to start with
the exogenous variables.
This isn't gonna moves. I
don't want to do that. Do this.
Yeah,
you exogenous variables.
Okay.
Are going to be the youth,
the people.
Okay. So I'll have individuals, I and
I, so let's call them individuals.
So you've seen why I use the word I,
I and I. Okay. And,
and what is it that characterizes
every individual a utility function?
So each is characterized by utility
and an endowment.
Okay. So to start with, let's
say then, so the individuals,
and we'll call the
individuals and the Gordon's
C and c. So let's just say
there are two goods, x and y
Hay. So an individual is going to be
characterized by utility function, uh,
say,
uh,
welfare function of x and y equals you.
I have ax plus V,
I have y.
Okay.
And an endowment,
e equals e,
x of y.
So for example, you could have,
I don't know, you could have,
uh,
this could be,
so let's just think about this.
So this is exactly the kind
of situation we had before.
We had precisely this going on before.
What was the endowment?
Every person began with money.
This could have been money before.
Okay.
And with football tickets.
Yeah.
And we said that the story that,
so these original marginalist argued
that it's part of human nature that the
more you get of something, the less and
less extra advantage that brings you.
And that's just, you know,
there may be exceptions.
Maybe you need to have something in order
to, you know, you need both shoes, uh,
in order to the shoes to
help. But then, you know,
every pair of shoes after that was going
to be less and less valuable to you.
And so beside from these
small, you know, uh,
blips that come from indivisibility is,
or things like that,
people's utility increases,
but at smaller and smaller rate
as they get more of everything,
that's just human nature.
They claim they even tried to
measure human nature and they, yeah.
And to measure utilities.
So they would try and measure
the temperature of the
skin and things like that
and see how it increased when you gave
people more of something and whether the
rate of increase, you know,
and how much they, you know,
smiled and stuff like that.
Whether that would actually change
in a lesser and lesser ways.
You add more and more utility where they,
they abandoned that sort of thing
eventually. But anyway, there I,
they kept the idea of
diminishing margin utility.
So we want to keep the idea that Ui
of acts and vi of why show diminishing
marginal utility.
Yeah.
So the way of saying that,
and I told you this is one of the,
so the first handout and the reading
list was a review of mathematics.
You should know. So diminishing
or, or if you don't know,
you have to learn diminishing margin.
Utility means something that looks
like that. It's a concave function.
So here's x,
here's utility and hears you.
I evac say it goes up
as you get more acts,
but at a rate that declines. So the
slope is getting smaller and smaller.
That's diminishing marginal utility.
So this curve that's increasing,
but at a lesser and lesser rate,
we can approximate with a continuous
differentiable curve that looks like that.
So it doesn't have the kinks here and a,
and that's exactly the kind
of assumption that you know,
seems reasonable to fit the facts
and at least for consumption.
Our main interest of course is at the
bottom here and financial equity room.
But we have to know what's going
on in the economy. You know,
all these finance professors,
as I said in business schools,
they ignored the part of the above.
They started right away with the assets
and the bonds said they didn't need to
pay any attention to what was
going on in the economy. Okay.
Because everything was going to be great.
And uh,
but we're going to find that there's a
big interaction between the financial
sector in the economic sector. That's
going to be the heart of what we're doing,
even though it was ignored and
finance most of the time. So anyway,
diminishing marginal utility,
um, for both of these.
So,
for instance,
we could have a hundred miles a hundred
x minus one half x squared plus y.
That's one example of utility function.
Okay? So that's going to be a
standard kind of utility function.
So the only two ones I'm ever going to
use or things like this are one third log
x plus two thirds blog.
Why whenever I write log,
I mean natural log.
Okay? Now how? So here's,
this is linear quadratic.
So listens quadratic,
in fact linear, quadratic. So maybe
both will be quadratic and this is uh,
this is logarithmic.
Now both of these have this property of,
of diminishing margin utility cause
I can take the derivative of this,
the derivative of 100 x
minus one half x squared.
So the marginal utility of x is equal
to 100 minus x and that obviously
declines.
So that's diminishing marginal utility.
And then the derivative here,
the margin utility with respect to act,
it depends on x again,
is going to be one third times one over x
is the derivative of the law, I guess
one of racks and this x gets bigger.
That also declines.
So these are the two functions that
we're going to use over and over again
because I want to make things
concrete with actual numbers.
So we'll always solve
examples with quadratic stuff.
Maybe everything will be quadratic or
linear. And with logarithmic stuff,
it was the only two functions you really
have to be totally comfortable with.
So you have to understand
what a derivative is. This
was a partial derivative.
So how much extra utility do
you get out of consuming more x?
If you've already got a certain
amount of x and your possession,
it's a hundred minus x.
How much more utility do you get out
of consuming more acts if this is your
utility? Um, when your consumption's
already a certain amount of x,
it's one third times one over x.
So those are the two things you have
to be comfortable with using. Okay,
so that, that's, that's the utility.
What else do we need to describe a person?
It's his endowment.
So with only two goods,
here's acts and here's why.
So we could have an endowment,
e I, x, e, I.
Y that's the endowment of x.
And y if a certain person,
all right, x, e, I. Why?
Okay, so this person, let's
say it's this top guy,
a hundred x minus one x squared plus y.
He has a certain utility function.
He's got a certain endowment.
Maybe there's somebody else over here
who I can put in a different color hall.
I think pink is a good color.
So another person might be
over here and this is e j a y
and
e.
J.
X. Okay, so Jay has a lot more of
why, and I have a lot more vex.
They're two different people,
but you could imagine not two people.
You could imagine 150 of you with
different endowments in different utility
functions are 300 million of you with
difference endowments and different
utility functions. And what general
like liberty was about is saying, well,
you've got all these people with
well-defined utility functions.
Those are the data. We may not know
them, but they know them themselves.
With all those utility functions and all
those endowments and throw 300 million
of them together,
or 150 of you together,
can you predict what's going to happen?
And is the thing that happens
good for the society? Okay?
So that's the problem with general
equilibrium. And it turns out that,
um,
with these simple utility functions,
it's very easy to solve frack
liver and predict what'll happen.
And things look great until you get
the financial equilibrium. Okay?
And we'll be able to solve them
either by hand or on a computer.
And we're going to take advantage of
that because we want concrete answers to
concrete problems and we want to interact
it with the financial world to see how
you know, to see what happens. So now,
so remember, what's the next step? The
first step is exogenous variables. Okay?
So we define the exogenous variables.
The next step is the endogenous variable.
So what are the endogenous
variable is going to be,
can the endogenous variables
are going to be the prices
and the trains
or final consumption's.
You can always deduce a trade from a
final consumption because if you know your
endowment, that exogenous thing
and you're consuming more of x,
then you're endowed with, he
must've bought that different
somewhere. And if you,
you know, if you're consuming
less, why then you started with,
you must have sold some of that.
Why in order to end up consuming less so
the endogenous variables and the prices
and the trains.
Now how can we make a general theory that
for an arbitrary number of people and
arbitrary number of goods you can solve
and figure out what's going to happen
that looks very much like the
example and has as a special case.
The example we did with we
did to me to begin with,
that's what happened with general life
Librium and I'm about to describe it.
So the next step is always
to write down the equilibrium
equilibrium as a bunch of
simultaneous equations.
Okay,
so what are all the equilibrium equation
is going to be and that's what's going
to be our model of what happens in the
world. Okay? There are any questions.
This is how are all doing here?
Is this was painfully repetitive of
what you know or, you know, just to get,
I need some feedback here.
How many of you haven't seen this before?
Everybody's seen this before.
What about all these people who emailed
me and said they were scientists and
philosophers and a psychologist and they
wanted to take economics the first day.
So you're one of those people maybe
didn't email me, but you, okay.
So this is first for you, but everybody
else, you've all seen this before. Okay,
well that's, that's good.
I can move along here.
So I'll keep looking at you.
Um,
I'll keep looking at you as I proceed
here. So don't feel bashful. You know,
all these, you know, speak up if it's
not making sense. Okay. So how do you,
so what was the,
what was the great conceptual advance?
It was one conceptual
advance was the budget set.
Now this will turn out to be
in, in economics. They've all,
the rest of the 140 of them have
all got this down, but it's,
but as soon as we turned it
into a financial problem,
they're not going to
be able to do it again,
even though it's going
to be the same idea.
So there's a budget set was
an extremely clever idea,
which I'll now repeat for them
and tell you for the first time.
But I can almost guarantee that of all
they all think it's obvious when we do
the first financial problem,
they aren't gonna be able to do it
even though it's the exact same idea.
So what's the idea? You begin with
your endowment EAI acts and DIY.
So this person has to
buy and sell x and y.
So the person says to himself, you know,
I've started with this x and y, you know,
I might like something that's better.
Now,
how can you illustrate what's
better for this person? Well,
Edgeworth as I mentioned,
um,
Edgeworth Edgeworth invented the
idea of the indifference curve.
So he says,
all the goods that are of the same utility
can be described by this indifference
curve x. You know this person or
you're a, her utility is one third log,
x plus two thirds log. Why?
Well if you, if you, um,
if you, uh, if she consumes less of
x enough extra Y, we'll put her up,
make her just indifferent to where she
was before because there's a trade off
between acts and why economics
is all about trade offs.
So this is her indifference curve. Maybe
his indifference curve looks like that.
Different slope. Okay. Entirely different.
So he thinks a lot of why
a little diminution and why
you better get a lot of x
to compensate him. She's kind of more
balanced and things x and y, you know,
unless she starts to get too much of x,
in which case why is
more important to her.
She in general is more balanced
than he is, but anyways,
they have different tastes,
different utility functions
and different endowments.
So what's going to happen in the end?
Well,
the budget's set
describes what she can do.
We're going to assume as
we did before those fork,
that cornerstone of economic reasoning.
Somehow when these hundred million people,
300 million people get together,
if they're going to
miraculously discover the price,
they're going to be screaming at each
other. But we don't care about that.
We just say for the
purposes of the big picture,
some price of x and y is going to emerge.
So equilibrium is going to be
a price of x and a price of y.
It's going to emerge. And now what is
this? What can she do? Well, she can say,
she can say, okay, given
my ex I can buy more acts.
Then I started with,
and if I do that,
the price of acts as Px.
So if I want to buy more,
I'm going to ha I have this already.
If I want to end up consuming XII,
so final consumption will be XII.
And why I,
this is the final consumption.
So my trade,
if I want to buy more,
I can express the idea that I'm buying
more by saying my final consumption is
bigger than my endowment.
So I've had to buy,
I've had to trade to get this much more,
which means I had to pay px
times this difference. Okay,
now how did I get the money for that?
Well,
I got the money for that
by selling some of y.
So I sold why I started with Eei,
Y
and I sold some of it because I
ended up with less than I started.
So the money I got by selling why
I can use to spend on buying x,
that's the basic budget constraint.
Now the cleverness is in realizing
that it doesn't matter which one.
So here excise bigger than the,
I asked, you're buying acts here,
why eyes less than DIY?
You're selling why?
And so the revenue you get from
selling y equals the expenditure.
You make them buying x.
So the cleverness is and realizing
it doesn't matter what the signs are,
if Exci is less than EAI x,
this equation still makes sense because
then you get a negative number, right?
You've gotten money by consuming
less acts. Then you started with,
so that's money you can use to buy.
Why and then why?
I will be, you'll be able to buy more live
than you started with. So this number,
we'll also be negative by
the same amount as this.
This is the extra value on why
this is the extra value on x.
So whether the x's and the y's are bigger
or smaller than the aix is re I wise,
this equation defines the budget
trading opportunities of the agent.
Now how did that go too fast?
Where you got that? Okay,
so he can write that a little
bit more simply by saying,
putting a plus here and reversing
the order, making it more symmetric.
So this is why I minus e y equals zero.
Okay,
so that's the budget set.
[inaudible]
agent I
and on the diagram, the budget set,
if I'm out of colors that show up,
I think all the others got vetoed.
I think orange was okay.
Okay. The budget set, then we'll
be something that looks like this.
Well,
it was terrible.
How bad can we get?
Okay,
so that budget set might
look something like a,
let's make it this way.
Okay.
Looks something like that. It's
a linear line that goes up. Um,
let's just forget this guy's budget set.
We'll do the other one night.
He can get it better in the picture.
So this one is budget set,
his budget set might look
something like that. Okay.
So his budget set, nevermind hers, it
goes off the page, hurt his budget set.
You start with us endowment. He can,
if the prices are given px and P,
y px and p why define a linear
tradeoff between x and Y in this case,
Jay, because you know the more x you
consume, the less why you have to consume.
And there's obvious and the amount of,
and there's going to be a linear trade
off between the two given by rearranging
these terms cause they're all gonna,
you know, these x and p why are fixed.
So those are just a linear
equation and EXCI and why.
And so that trade off is
given by that budget set.
So Mr Pink is going to try,
given his opportunities on this budget
set to pick the combination of x and y,
then it's best for him.
And so that's going to turn out
to be something that's right here.
Because no other combination of x and Y,
we'll give them as much utility as that.
Hey, did that make sense? All right.
So that's it. That's the main,
that's the main lesson. So, uh,
how do you describe novel whole
Echo Librium conditions? Well,
so equilibrium now if you can see
this aqua Librium is defined bye
bye.
What it's defined by Px p,
Y
and x and Y
for all Imr.
Yeah.
It's just the prices that emerge and
what everybody final consumption's that
everybody chooses of x and y. They're
only two goods here. So the price of x,
the price of y, what every
person I ends up with x, Y,
and why and what has to be, what has to
be the case, what has to be the case?
The first equation is going to be that,
um,
the final consumptions of everybody have
to equal the final endowments because
everyone who buys has to be
met by another cell. Remember,
equilibrium was priced taking ancient
optimization, rational expectations,
and market clearing. Price taking means
everybody knows what the prices are.
Miraculously px and p why before they act.
Age and optimization we're going to come
to it means they do the best thing they
can.
Rational expectations means even though
they're only buying one good and there
are thousands of the economy,
they understand all the
prices and when they act,
they're looking in,
you know,
they're taking into account all
the trade offs they could make.
So they realize the whole vector of
prices and market clearing means for any
buyer, there's a seller. So market
clearing means summation from I
avec sy has to equal summation.
I am,
I have the endowment, Eei, I
have x. So in this picture,
if I added this to this,
this was the endowment.
So add this vector to that vector.
I get this thing over here and this
is going to be the total endowment
in the economy.
Okay,
so this total endowment,
Eei x,
I had over every person I
what the total endowment is.
So add his endowment of x to
this guys and downwind of x,
and I get the total endowment of X.
I had his endowment of why to her or her
endowment of wine to his endowment of
wine. They get the total
endowment of why? Okay,
so the first two equations are summation.
I and I,
why I equal summation,
I and I of Eei. Why?
The third equation is everybody's
going to choose on their budget.
Set everyone, this person, Mr Pink here,
he's going to choose not
inside his budget, said he
can't choose outside, right?
Because you know, spending is,
there's no point in wasting money.
He's going to buy the combination
of x and y that lies on his budgets,
that that does as well as he possibly can.
So the equation here is going to be the P.
Um,
I times x xy minus e I x plus p y
times y minus D I y is equal to zero.
You know what?
I could do this for Jay to just,
since I've got a picture of this is p x,
this is p y p x times x,
j minus e I j.
So I'm doing a special
case now with two people.
YJ MINUS J equals zero.
Okay?
Okay.
So everybody's on their budget said,
so he's on his budget set.
She or he's on his budget,
said she's going to be on her budget
set. Her budget set, by the way,
is better than his because her budget
set is going to look like this,
right?
It's gotta be parallel to his cause.
The price is she faces are the same
and her endowments worth more than his.
So her budget says further out.
Okay?
So that's what he does. That's what
she does. Or that's what she does.
That's what he does. And
now the fifth one, okay,
so now we have the two mysterious
equations that are left.
So how do we express the idea that
the choices XII and why I buy I,
that's her. Okay. And
her budget's, you know,
she's going to optimize by
choosing here somewhere,
okay?
This is her indifference
curve, right? Looked like that.
So that's what she's going to do. And
remember, he decides he's going to choose.
So how can you turn her choice
and his choice into an equation?
Well,
this was invented by a
German Guy Goslin's in 1851
and then rediscovered by
Jeavons Manga and wall Ross.
Same three I mentioned several times.
Now,
this is the marginal
revolution in economics.
What they said is you can turn
the behavior of, of individuals,
of humans,
as Gossan said,
I can do for the bodies on earth with
Copernicus did for the bodies and heaven
find equations that describe their motion.
What is it that people are going to do
to say that you're choosing the best
possible thing means that the slope of
the budget set is equal to the slope of
your indifference curve. But what is
the slope of your indifference curve?
That's the trade off between x and y.
Okay,
so what does it mean if you
get a little bit more less,
you get a little bit less x,
you're losing the margin utility of x.
You can a little bit more why you're
gaining the margin utility of y.
If the price of x and y are the same,
then it had better be that the Mars
utility of x is equal to the marginal
utility of why?
Because you could always give up one
unit of acts and get one unit of why.
If this is optimal and you could give
up one unit of x and get to and get two
units, sorry if the margin Tillery Foy
was double the margin utility vacs,
then you would give up that one,
you know,
the Max and you get two extra you tiles
by taking the one unit of why what you
can afford by selling one univacs
and utility would be, you know,
much higher than it was here. And so, um,
you wouldn't be optimizing by doing that.
So the final equation is you're optimizing
if and only if the margin utility of
Roi of x divided by the margin utility
of I have y equals px over p y.
Okay. And, and for, and the last
equation is the same thing for Jay.
The margin Youtube William J of x divided
by the margin utility of Jay of why
has the equal px over p y
is a why is that? Again, that's the
whole, that's the trickiest equation.
That's the one that Marx and Adam
Smith and not even Ricard on the most
brilliant one of the mall.
Not even Ricardo, could figure
that out. This equation,
marginal utility wait until
1871 and again to repeat it,
it's of course very obvious now,
but wasn't at the time.
How can you describe what
these people are doing?
You have to figure out the budget
constraint. That's what they can afford.
And then they're going to choose the
point on their budget constraint,
which maximizes their utility.
Okay?
But that just means in the picture makes
the indifference curve tangent to the
budget set, which means that
you set so, and what does it,
what is the slope of the indifference
curve while the trade off between x and y?
That leaves you in different,
how much acts do you have to give up
and take to get an extra unit of y and
still be in different,
it's determined by the ratio of the margin
utility of x to the margin utility of
why? Because those are the, you
know, when you give up a unit of x,
you're losing the march utility of x
when you're getting a unit of why you're
getting the margin utility of why.
If you can trade them off in the market,
it's three to one. You optimize
when in your own personal valuation,
you're trading them off on the margin
at three to one. Okay? So how is that?
You really follow that?
Okay,
so that's an idea that took 50 years to
figure out and you claim you figured it
out now in five minutes. So
that's good. So, so anyway, I, uh,
so you'll have a chance of the
problem set to get practice with.
So those are the equations we
now basically have described, um,
economic Ecqua Librium.
So we now have the ability to play with
all kinds of models as we'll start in
the next class doing,
solving for economic equilibrium,
figuring out what will happen and then
complicating it by adding a financial
sector and see how that affects,
affects what goes on in equilibrium.